l'obésité nous coûte 30 milliards
collectivement au Canada chaque année
les boissons sucrées demeurent la
première source de sucre au pays pour
rendre ça moins accessible et rendre les
bons produits accessibles depuis plus de
10 ans l'idée de taxer les boissons
sucrées fait son chemin au Canada c'est
demander par les groupes qui luttent
contre l'obésité depuis des années en
septembre 2022 Terre-Neuve et Labrador
est devenu la première province au
Canada a instauré une telle taxe
est-ce que ça a été une surprise pour
vous cette l'arrivée de cette taxe là
dans cette province il y a plus de 85
pays dans le monde qui ont déjà implanté
une taxe sur les boissons sucrées donc
c'est une mesure qui a sa place puis on
a été très content de voir que la
province de Terre-Neuve et Labrador
emboîter le pas également
cette nouvelle taxe de vincentes le
litre touchant entre autres les boissons
gazeuses les boissons aromatisées aux
fruits et les boissons énergisantes
Richard proud et chercheuse et a pour
mandat d'évaluer les effets de cette
nouvelle taxe
est-ce que les boissons sucrées ont
vraiment un impact sur l'obésité et
certaines maladies chroniques il y a un
impact direct qui démontré depuis
plusieurs années pas seulement sur
l'obésité mais aussi le développement
des maladies chroniques que ce soit
l'hypertension le diabète et même on
pense qu'il y a un lien maintenant avec
certains cancers
les prix et faire baisser la
consommation de ces boissons
Antoine Genet Grégoire a étudié la
taxation des boissons sucrées à travers
le monde et son éventuel instauration au
Québec dans les pays comme le Mexique le
Chili vous parlez de ville américaine
qui ont eu cette taxation là qu'est-ce
qu'on a vu concrètement ça a été quoi
les fait l'impact il y a presque
toujours une diminution des achats si on
augmente le prix des boissons sucrées de
20% en général les ventes vont baisser
d'à peu près 20%
la Coalition québécoise sur la
problématique du poids milite depuis
2010 pour qu'une telle taxe soit
appliquée au Québec est-ce que vous
pensez que le gouvernement place va
instaurer cette taxe dans les prochaines
années le lobby de l'industrie des
boissons sucrées est extrêmement fort
c'est des compagnies qui sont
enregistrées en bourse donc leur
objectif premier c'est de faire des
revenus et non pas de protéger la santé
de la population
les géants tels que Pepsi et Coca-Cola
sont représentés par l'Association
canadienne des boissons qui voit de
mauvaise oeil l'arrivée de cette taxe
dans une première province canadienne
très déçu d'initiative de la province on
pense pas que c'est une initiative qui
vraiment va avoir un impact sur le tour
de taille des gens d'Internet du
Labrador c'est une approche qui est
dépassée selon nous qui affectent
les populations plus pauvres donc qu'un
état de significatif sur le coup du
panier d'épicerie donc pour nous c'est
vraiment une initiative qui vise à
augmenter les revenus de l'État cibler
un produit
qui aura pas vraiment d'impact sur la
santé de la population
cet axe à Terre-Neuve et Labrador
devrait générer 9 millions de dollars
pour vous et moi c'est beaucoup d'argent
pour le gouvernement internats l'intérêt
d'une table d'axes comme ça c'est pas de
lever des fonds le but c'est que les
gens consomment une boisson sucrée donc
à terme on devrait lever 0 dollar le bus
et de changer le comportement mais en
attendant évidemment ça se fait pas du
jour au lendemain on touche des revenus
une des choses qu'on peut faire
justement dans un contexte
inflationniste et prendre cet argent-là
et essayer de le réinvestir dans quelque
chose qui a rapport avec nos objectifs
par exemple de santé publique
c'est ce que le gouvernement terre ne
vient fera avec l'argent récolté
qui a été fait par des chercheurs sur
l'instauration de cet axe là au Québec
principalement ça ressemble à quoi le
modèle économique en fait demain matin
au Québec si on importait une taxation
des boissons sucrées à la hauteur de 20
sous parlées on pourrait générer des
revenus à investir en prévention
d'environ 50 millions de dollars par
année
on pense que si les états puis les
gouvernements va avoir un impact
significatif sur la sur l'obésité sur la
santé des populations c'est davantage
avec des mesures sur l'information la
sensibilisation est au courant de
d'adapter nos choix alimentaires et nos
choix de poissons en fonction de notre
type d'activité physique on peut croire
que c'est un peu paternaliste comme
comme mesure va falloir qu'on pourrait
faire de la sensibilisation
je pense que le paternalisme a le dos
large c'est quelque chose qui est tout
le temps dit à propos des taxes sur des
boissons sucrées vous allez pas
contrôler qu'est-ce qu'on mange
qu'est-ce qu'on boit mais pourtant on a
une foule de mesure paternaliste dans
une foule de secteur on a des limites de
vitesse quand on a décidé que l'excès de
vitesse c'est un vrai problème on n'est
pas juste dit aux gens que c'est un
problème on a fait des annonces choc on
a aussi multiplié les amendes on a
multiplier les contrôles l'information
c'est c'est visible c'est le fun c'est
pas très cher mais quand on constate que
le problème est sérieux il faut aussi
utiliser des moyens un peu plus crédible
et la vaccination c'est un des moyens
les plus sérieux
en décembre 2022 l'Organisation Mondiale
de la Santé a plaidé en faveur de la
taxation des boissons sucrées
pour le moment aucune province
canadienne ne semble vouloir emboîter le
pas à Terre-Neuve et Labrador au Québec
le ministère des Finances n'a pas
accepté notre demande entrevue le bureau
de Christian Dubé ministre de la Santé
et des Services sociaux du Québec nous a
fait parvenir un courriel pour réitérer
que sa priorité demeure la prévention
est-ce qu'on voit la corrélation entre
cette taxe là la base de la consommation
mais aussi une amélioration de la santé
de la population on n'a pas
nécessairement donné qui démontre en ce
moment que ça a permis d'améliorer la
santé de la population c'est des choses
qui sont difficiles à mesurer parce que
la santé est influencée par une tonne de
facteurs l'équation elle est simple il y
a des réductions qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 20% de consommation de ces
boissons sucrées chez les gens dont
l'éducation les revenus sont les plus
faibles donc ça a un impact important
dans une population chez qui les
maladies chroniques et l'obésité est
aussi plus fréquente
donc
c'est un ensemble de mesures dont
celle-ci qui peut nous aider justement à
réduire le fardeau et améliorer la
qualité de la vie
la Coalition québécoise sur la
problématique du poids entend bien
continuer son combat dans ce dossier en
plaidant aussi pour le bien-être de
l'environnement la production et la
consommation de boissons sucrées ont des
impacts sur l'environnement on parle
notamment des gaz à effet de serre qui
sont générés par le transport par le
transport par les déchets à usage unique
comme les contenants de plastique ou
d'aluminium donc non seulement c'est pas
bon pour notre santé mais c'est
également pas bon pour la planète
[Musique]